alright so president Trump is
threatening to cut Obama care subsidies
as a way of forcing the Democrats to
capitulate well he will call it
negotiate but really to capitulate to
his demands so on Wednesday in an
interview he revealed that his next move
was going to be to use the health care
subsidies as a weapon to get in the
Democrats to negotiate these are the
subsidies that are paid to health care
corporations for Lord Lord premiums he's
threatening essentially and this is the
Democrats agree that he's threatening to
hold Americans hostage so that he can
get his way with the repeal and a
replacement plan for Obamacare the
problem is that you know it's not just
that you can't get Democrats on board
you couldn't get Republicans on board
Pat and you can't get them aboard
because you didn't have a coherent plan
yeah because the freedom caucus thought
that this was Obamacare light so there
was this weird coalition of people on
the very very far right and Democrats
who were just voting against Trump care
but also Donald Trump made this threat
all along he said that if Trump care
wasn't going to pass then he would just
let Obamacare fail on its own merits
yeah i mean i agree with you i mean one
hundred percent it was it was a
combination of the freedom caucus who
now the chairman of the freedom caucus
Dave Brett Republican of Virginia has
come out and said apparently they're
negotiating now they're negotiating with
Trump and they're coming up with a plan
that's palatable to the freedom caucus
but here's the thing if it's palatable
to the freedom caucus it is going to be
highly detrimental to Republicans that
are coming from purple states that are
coming from swing states because
Obamacare is overwhelmingly popular now
because people have paid attention to
find out what's actually in it and the
freedom caucus the reason they oppose
Trump care / Ryan care is because it
wasn't quite drakonian enough it didn't
really cut enough it didn't hurt oh
right the right amount of people so for
the freedom caucus to now be on the side
of Donald Trump are trying to negotiate
something this is not going to play well
either is it possible that they're going
to go to Obamacare twice and fail twice
in the most spectacular fashion and
there are also plenty of Republican
governors and lawmakers who are
benefiting greatly from
I can't expansion so they're not going
to do something that kicks hundreds of
thousands of their own constituents off
of their healthcare coverage and you
know it there they wanted to be able to
do this pad and get away with it by not
having it enacted until after 2018 after
the midterm elections but the reality of
it is is that so many people have tuned
in to what's actually in Obamacare now
that they're threatening to get rid of
it that the Republican Party president
Trump is one hundred percent going to
own this no matter if it succeeds or if
it fails whatever they touch they are
going to own now there's a clip from CNN
this morning that is absolutely absurd
and obscene in my opinion and this is of
Jeffrey Lourdes a commentator describing
Donald Trump in this fashion with regard
to health care elephant I I want to say
something here that I know will probably
drive Simone crazy but I think of
President Trump is the martin luther
king of health care I'm exactly Jeffrey
president I was a kid pranic granted he
did not want to introduce the civil
rights bill because he said it wasn't
popular you didn't have the votes for it
etc dr. King kept putting people in the
streets in harm's way to put the
pressure on so the call would be
introduced that's what I finally i'm
sure my homegirl Simone Sanders probably
took him to task really well and I know
that we're on FCC regulated channels but
what the entire Hill is this man
thinking and saying he's such a
revisionist history that I can't even
begin I actually can and I will but what
do you think first bad it's an absurd
comment to make and I think he was right
in the sense that he was going to upset
a lot of people by making that comment
yeah he's a man it doesn't make sense
because Martin Luther King said that of
all the forms of inequality injustice
and health care is the most shocking and
human humane first of all it's a great
great quote I actually I'm thinking if I
have ever heard that quote so tip my hat
to you on that one fact that's great but
i'm trying to think you know what is it
about conservatives that they always
want to co-op the legacy of people that
they were probably would have been
complicit in his death at it's time I
they want to call off the legacy of dr.
King
now they're even trying to do it too to
make him a tool of hurting millions of
Americans because as we all know you
know Donald Trump is the martin luther
king of health care I mean what the hell
well it's because they'll argue that
Martin Luther King and Abraham Lincoln
as well were Republicans but that was
before the party switched yeah when LBJ
signed the Civil Rights Act the South
went from Democrats two Republicans and
on a Dixiecrat party it was a complete
flip for what we have now well I mean
Pat you're throwing something into the
conversation you're throwing context
into the conversation and Republicans
and their son Pfizer some Democrats but
right now we're talking about Democrats
Republicans don't want context they
don't want the reality that if you
really believe that you're the party of
Lincoln how can you explain the fact
that you are now the party of the
Confederate flag waving south against
which Lincoln ways an entire Civil War
it just doesn't work like that I mean it
sounds nice to most of the public who
don't realize that the parties have
switched but if you just simply explain
that so what happened it's completely
under markets their argument real quick
well I want to present a new rule of
politics double the number one rule Sean
Spicer learned the hard way don't
compare anyone to Hitler the second rule
should be there is only one dr. King in
a very positive in a very good way don't
compare your petty agenda to dr. King
Geoffrey get you some learning and
somewhere somehow just just go away
Jeffrey go away